le résultat étant tellement serré que
nous préférons procéder à un recomptage
complet
c'est le scénario le plus improbable qui
vient de se jouer l'égalité parfaite
entre les deux listes concurrentes au
premier comptage des bulletins scénario
tellement improbable qu'il ait décidé de
recompter est là aussi nouveau
rebondissement plus question d'égalité
une des deux listes arrivées en tête
avec une voix d'avancé
les candidats la délégation spéciale
tout le monde a décidé de procéder à un
recomptage complet ce qui va lui demande
une petite heure une voix d'écart mais
pour qui quel candidat prg instants pour
madame boisorieux liste boisorieux
claudine boisorieux la maire sortante
elle et son adversaire sont en train de
revivre la même soirée qu'au deuxième
tour des municipales de 2014
une voix d'écart entre les deux listes
un résultat tellement incertain qu'il
avait débouché sur l'annulation des
élections mais cette fois ci claudine
boisorieux veut une victoire sans
contestation possible et accepte donc un
troisième recomptage des bulletins
j'aurais voulu une victoire plus large
surtout met dans une situation mais
aussi juste que celle là qui
plus raisonnable
de décider d'accepter un recomptage
total il y avait une voix d'écart et
quand il ya le volet car on recompte ce
qui aurait dû être fait déjà la dernière
fois voilà simplement c'est la loi c'est
de respect de la démocratie clamecy
terre de gauche de vie depuis 2008 des
élections à suspense entre boisorieux la
dissidente socialiste et un candidat
officiel du ps les électeurs ont du mal
à trancher je pense qu'elle avait
découpé en deux il faudrait seulement
pensé à faire quelque chose pour
réconcilier parce que là c'est
l'impression que c'est couper pour un
certain temps peut pas être en guerre
tout le temps on peut pas être un
campagne électorale tout le temps ne pas
être dans les attaques permanentes
il va falloir passer à autre chose
vendredi claudine boisorieux 74 ans
retrouvera son fauteuil de maire pour
achever son deuxième mandat consécutif
et à rebondissements